now what I mean the earth is gone and
not only are you stuck on the space
station above it there's not a single
soul left with you you are all by
yourself in space and you have nowhere
to go how long would your supplies last
and what would you do when those
supplies are finished this is what if
and here's what would happen if you were
the last human stranded in space the
International Space Station the one and
only research facility orbiting the
Earth every half hour and now it's your
forever home unless you prefer living on
Mars but more on that later the ISS is
equipped with laboratories living areas
a gym and unimaginably expensive toilet
and it has a supply of food not the
worst place to be stranded but you might
change your mind about that
[Music]
don't start to panic just take a deep
breath
it's 7:00 a.m. and you wake up after
your 8 hour sleep you make yourself a
protein filled breakfast and get to work
this space station isn't gonna repair
itself
you carry on conducting repairs and then
you might exercise for a couple of hours
everything seems normal until you
remember that what you saw yesterday
wasn't a dream you try to open a line of
communication with earth to see if
anyone's still down there no luck
you're alone and you can't go back to
what's left of Earth you can't talk to
anyone nothing and you need to start
dealing with it the first thing you'd
want to do is see how much food is left
a team of six people could last on the
ISS for about three months since you
were left all by yourself you could
easily do fine for 18 months or more but
you need to plan your rations two meals
a day is a good start and you could grow
fresh veggies right on the space station
to keep you going longer you'd keep
recycling and reusing the water
this water was always cleaner than the
water on earth anyway for the bathroom
you'd keep using a suction tube to pee
into and this waste container is for
number two it's equipped with a small
suction pump so that everything goes in
the right direction no auto flush and
nope seed heater so much for the 19
million dollar toilet while you're
floating around with the sweat pooling
around your body instead of evaporating
think of this you'd never take a shower
again I mean a good running water shower
those would be gone together with the
earth you'd have to get by squirting a
bit of water on your skin and shampooing
with no rinse shampoo whether your
planet is destroyed or not your body is
built for living on the ground and not
in the microgravity environment on the
ISS your bones would keep losing calcium
and your muscles would keep losing mass
this is because in the weightlessness
your body doesn't need bones or muscles
much if you want to keep those you'd
need to hit the gym
astronauts workout as much as four hours
in every 16 hour period there's not much
of a gym on the ISS but at least you can
use the treadmill in a sort of
mechanical bicycle and after a long day
of working exercising being in a tube
eating dehydrated food and trying to
stay sane you'd head back to your
sleeping pod and just try to sleep a
little
you could live your day-to-day space
life all by yourself for a year or two
your body would be getting weaker and
the shock and grief of losing everyone
you knew would be overwhelming you the
thought of never being able to go back
to earth could cause anxiety panic
attacks and depression the total
isolation would impact your ability to
survive on the ISS and without proper
maintenance the space station would
plunge uncontrollably down to what's
left of Earth and splash into the ocean
but what if instead of giving up and
slowly waiting for your end on this
enormous craft you could make good use
of it I'm talking about moving the
entire station away from Earth's
leftovers the ISS was built for the
lower Earth orbit but if you had enough
fuel in the tank could you try to use it
as a spaceship and accelerated all the
way to Mars what have you got to lose
anyway you know I'd really like to give
you some emotional support you are the
last person in all of humanity and
you're watching what if that's just Wow
but the truth is you wouldn't make it to
Mars the ISS is designed for lower Earth
orbit it just wouldn't work for the Red
Planet or for our moon for that matter
plus you wouldn't survive very long in
the harsh space radiation and the ISS
itself is getting too old to handle
space travel it just wouldn't work
unless you happen to get stranded on a
next generation space station that
required fewer repairs and spacewalks
that would be fully self-sustaining and
free flying then you'd call it an early
retirement and keep living on it till
your life comes to an end
or you could get out there and explore
space beyond the solar system you might
find an exoplanet you could live on
maybe even encounter alien life but
that's a story for another whatever
[Music]
you